[Musique]
quand on dit pablo escobar y a ceux qui
pensent baron de la drogue d'autres qui
pensent à la saline archos et ceux qui
le confondent avec picasso
pour les derniers qui me retourner à
l'école les autres ont raison pablo
escobar a été l'un des plus grands
narcotrafiquants que la terre ait connu
installé à medellin en colombie c'est là
qu'il perdra la vie en 1993 pablo
escobar me currat plus le parrain de la
drogue a été tué par les policiers à
medellin en colombie dans les années 80
son business est sans conteste l'un des
plus importants au monde à cette période
avec son cartel il aura alimenté 80% du
trafic de cocaïne aux états unis un
business plus que florissant qui aurait
rapporté chaque année un chiffre
d'affaires avoisinant les 22 milliards
de dollars comme dit le proverbe en
matière de richesse et de bonté le bon
chiffre
c'est la moitié de la moitié avoir mis
la colombie à feu et à sang activement
recherché par les autorités locales
les autorités américaines qui tue et le
lendemain de l'anniversaire de ses 44
ans est encore presque trente ans après
sa mort ce nom est connu à travers le
monde ce soir sa femme maria sur notre
plateau pour tout le monde y est sûre la
vie secrète de pablo escobar
maria isabel son devoir d'être avec nous
on dit merci beaucoup alors tout le
monde vous attendez on était tous comme
des fous de vous recevoir très heureux
donc merci d'être là
c'est la traduction traduction dans
l'autre ça ce mode saas pauvres ces
squats recevoir merci je parle un petit
peu allemand
merci pr alors la première question
qu'on se pose c'est est qu'est ce que ça
fait d'être là la femme de pablo escobar
parce que je sais que auditoire vous
n'aviez aucune idée de ses activités
ma cm temps il vient juste
d'ouvrir mon coeur
que je me suis sentie exclue socialement
durant des années et je pense que
je peux vraiment m'exprimer
alors je dis vous eaton en livre comment
aurais je pu imaginer mon époux un
trafiquant international de drogue je le
pensais entrepreneur à succès dans
l'élevage et la promotion immobilière et
jeune politicien apprécier comment vous
avez vécu toutes ces années à côté de
lui sont tout de suite savoir qu'il
était jusqu'en 82 c'est
demain qu'un set je me suis rien
six garçons du quartier une personne
très humble qui n'avait pas d'argent
donc formé quelque chose à mon texte est
une erreur de satie et cette première
année de notre mariage alors vous êtes
tombée amoureuse lui à 12 ans c'est ça
c'est qu'il en a déjà trois à douze ans
on avait 23 ans il en avait 23 vous avez
partagé sa vie pendant 21 ans
c'est
génial il avait 23 ans doit comporter
j'ai partagé
ces mises à présent
la finale apparaît
absolument pas partager notre quotidien
quand vous avez appris qu'il était c'est
ça a été quand votre votre action vient
en avait parlé vous avez une
discussion avec lui
les femmes n'ont pas vraiment le droit
de poser des questions d'avoir décidé
donc nous eh bien nous faisons les
tâches domestiques de la maison nous
nous occupions des enfants mais nous
n'avions pas beaucoup de possibilités
nous exprimer
donc il n'y a pas eu de dissiper de
discussions
non
non c'est un moment de ma vie ça n'a pas
été possible à qui vous en avait parlé
alors à votre famille
votre famille et vos amis ou pas du tout
pouviez pas en parler en plus
j'en parle mais avec mes amis
proches les amis de l'école
le temps et
ont pu poser des questions lui ni ailier
qui oui
vous êtes mariée avec lui vous aviez 15
ans et vous avez découvert véritablement
ses activités neuf ans plus tard il vous
disait qu'il faisait de l'immobilier et
pendant ces neuf années là vous voyez
bien qu'il avait déjà des gardes du
corps qui avaient des armes dans les
voitures et tout ça vous ne vous n'avez
rien rien vu pendant que vous trouvez
pas ça bizarre pendant neuf ans qu'il
est désarmé tout ça pour un agent
immobilier
n l'entamé invincible au début au début
de sa vie il a les cheveux pâles gardes
du corps
qu'il est entré en politique sept ans
plus tard alors donc c'était vraiment
quelqu'un qui était acceptable
socialement faut remettre les choses
dans leur contexte
chaque étape de sa vie
dans le livre vous dites qu'on vous a
reproché de ne pas l'avoir dénoncé de
m'avoir dit quand vous êtes vous vous
êtes rendu compte de qui il s'agissait
et votre réponse elle est à la fois très
belle mais en même temps elle me paraît
un peu courte vous dites je l'aimais et
en même temps vous dites aussi c'était
un type dont j'avais peur il y avait un
double visage c'est à dire il y avait le
pablo à la maison et puis pablo escobar
celui qui faisait peur à tout le monde
je l'aimé c'est suffisant pour ne pas
dénoncer
mahb l'eau était le père de mes enfants
et en colombie il ya une loi
ne peut pas on ne doit pas dénoncer sa
famille quoi qu'il en soit moi j'avais
très peur j'étais complètement paralysée
face à l'horreur il avait extrêmement
peur de perdre mes enfants justement si
je faisais cela est-ce que pablo était
un homme à qui tout le monde obéit c'est
alors parce que vous aviez vous avez des
enfants est cuit en 77 vous étiez encore
au lycée quand vous avez mis au monde
juan pablo votre premier fils étant 84
vous avez ensuite une fille manuela
c'était quel genre de ce père pablo
escobar étaient présents ils
sont occupés il essayé de leur faire
faire des études ou pas du tout
dans la première partie de sa vie au
cours de cette première année dont je
viens d'arrêter
très présent avec juan pablo justement à
cela
il a mené à l'école participé aux
réunions avec les parents d'élèves en
fait c'était un père tout à fait normal
qu'ils rêvaient que son fils fasse des
études
en 84 lorsque la naissance de votre
fille c'est là que votre vie va basculer
puisque le 30 avril cette année là ce
que vous dites le ministre de la justice
a été assassinée par les complices de
votre mari est à partir de ce moment là
vous avez eu l'impression d'être une
fugitive c'est ça
cm et le e101 oui en
1984 30 avril ait eu un avant et un
après pour les colombiens et pour nos en
tant de familles
c'est là que nous nous sommes rendu
compte
de cette violence
lui créer provoqué à ce moment vous avez
réagi sur à toutes ces horreurs voilà
que vous étiez voilà vous êtes dit quoi
vous avez réagi comment vous étiez
triste vedette dit que ce que je fais là
kg j'ai fait j'ai je dois je dois faire
quelque chose ou qu'est ce que vous
disiez
notamment
quand j'étais enceinte de huit mois et
demi de ma deuxième
mère à ce moment là et
je suis parti en hélicoptère à travers
la jungle pour trouver un endroit au
panama ou
pouvoir accoucher alors neuf années se
sont ensuite écoulé neuf années de peur
de traque jusqu'au 2 décembre
1993 pablo vous appelle par téléphone
mais vous étiez sur écoute ce qui a
permis de géolocaliser son repère une
opération ensuite est menée et pablo
escobar perdra la vie abattu par la
police colombienne
ce coup de fil il doit rester dans votre
tête
oui absolument
prometic il fallait pas que je me
préoccupe qui leur étaient en train de
faire tout son possible pour que nos
questions des jeunes filles en fait
qu'il l'avait toujours fait
c'est une question que je me pose qu'est
ce qu'il faisait alors pour
nous permettre de vivre dans le
bien-être alors que en revanche toutes
ces actions généré beaucoup de haine
contre nous vous lui en voulez de ça
c est moche alors oui il ya beaucoup de
douleur on hamm est un mélange ses
sentiments pour maison d'arrêt hommes de
la mort y sont nés qui sont le fruit de
l'amour
le rêve d'avoir une maison ensemble et
toute l'horreur
aussi bien eux que moi même et tout le
pays a vendu vivre alors justement dans
les deux ans comment vous avez qu à vos
enfants ce qui était leur père
au
fils avait 16 ans
il comprenait pas bien la situation mais
avec ma fille j'ai beaucoup plus tarder
parce que ça a été une vie tellement
tragique que moi même je fais du mal à
la comprendre alors je n'avais même pas
les mots pour lui expliquer pour
expliquer cela une petite fille de 8 ans
ça oui bonjour comment allez vous tout
ce qui est un comble c'est qu'on
s'imagine une vie fastueuse à bosco
barcella il y a des milliards et en fait
ça n'a duré que très peu d'années où ça
a été un peu de plaisir des haciendas
qui est une 5e c1 par votre action ça
doit quand même temps sept heures fastes
pour vous
pour nous ça n'a duré que quatre ans
une quatre ans seulement c'est ça alors
on va reparler de ce jour ce 2 décembre
2000 1993 quand il vous appelle vous
avez vécu ça commence comme c'est le
pire souvenir de votre vie c'est presque
un soulagement
parce que moi je suis aussi étonné que
pablo escobar se dit j va vous appeler
c'est quand même il y avait énormément
de chances qu'il soit sur écoute est ce
que c'est pas un acte manqué en plus ici
avec ce qui vous a dit
exactement voilà il savait que c'était
presque la fin pour lui il s'est dit je
vais je vais vous sauver il va vous
sauver
que par escobar elle a décidé de mourir
à ce moment-là ça
le téléphone c'était la mort
[Musique]
nous étions entre la vie et la mort est
il
que nous vivions ça a été son choix
c'est ça oui mathieu pardon mais est-ce
qui vous a laissé de l'argent ou et de
quoi avez-vous aujourd'hui
[Musique]
ne nous a pas laissés d'argent
c'est eh bien ils sont revenus à l'état
colombien et sur qui les accueillent
quant aux ennemis de pablo
lorsque nous avons pour parler tu es
nous leur avons remis le reste des
propriétés parce que moi je n'ai jamais
été en contact avec son argent je n'ai
jamais su où il avait gardé et donc gelé
remis aux ennemis ce que j'avais à ce
moment là
nous avons le soutien de l'état
colombien pour pouvoir quitter et puis
avec le temps avec ma famille jusqu'à ce
que nous avons commencé à travailler
j'ai eu ce soutien alors vous parler
d'argent c'est vrai qu'elle n'est aussi
un truc c'est pas c'est fou c'est celle
ya un pactole qui avait été découvert
par le neveu du plus célèbre trafiquant
de lennik pabos quoi nous connaissent
comme art qui a découvert dans la maison
de son oncle une cache contenant des 18
millions de dollars
c'est pas chez matthieu delormeau
tableau escobar était septième fortune
mondiale de son vivant il avait de
nombreuses cachettes d'argent et de
matérialité septième fortune mondiale
pablo escobar c'est fou parce que ce que
disait benjamin c'est qu'il était
septième fortune mondiale et vous voilà
c'est essayer vous et où l'argent vous
vous avez là
dans la dans la saisie si elle est un
fantasme autour du trésor caché par des
millions de dollars cachés dans la forêt
équatoriale donc c'est apparemment il a
pris un magot énorme qui n'attiraient
que par le passé ne déraille pas parler
de cette légende j'aimais gens peut-être
de façon surprenante
je me pose les mêmes questions que vous
et moi j'ai la conscience tranquille
la façon dont je vis
ma vie quotidienne à buenos aires donc
pour moi c'est une question qui fait
partie d'un fantasme
beaucoup de gens
qui ont profité de pablo escobar mais
pas sa famille alors
après la mort de palm os vont rester
cinq ans sous le choc et le pire est à
venir car aucun pays de souhaitez vous
accueillir personne ne voulait
prendre les personnes et entreprises est
monté
c'est n'a rien compris c'est vrai aucun
pays au monde
voulait nous accueillir
pourquoi nous avons dû changer
d'identité
parce que le nom de est ce qu elle
n'avait pas sa place dans le monde
l'état colombien nous a soutenus
grâce à une aide humanitaire
qui nous est venue du mozambique nous
avons pu quitter le pays un an plus tard
alors votre parcours on lit dans livre
c'est celui d'une femme trompée humiliée
traqué mais dans le livre ce qui est
magnifique c'est que vous lui clamé
encore votre amour
les teams début était le père de mes
enfants c'est l'homme que j'ai connu à
12 ans mais je ne peux pas
je peux pas renier et dire évidemment
d'écrire ce livre samaha côté des lames
beaucoup de travail avec des
spécialistes en criminologie avec une
neuroscientifique et pour moi ça a été
extrêmement douloureux
changer l'image d'un homme qui à un
moment donné a été mon mari et le père
de mes enfants ça fait bientôt trente
ans que pablo escobar et est décédé
j'en garde encore des traumatismes des
peines
c'est
25 ans sont écoulés pour que moi je me
serais qui permet à la fois et avoir le
courage pouvoir écrire la vie ce que
j'ai fait était une j'ai senti aux côtés
de pablo se complaît oui elle a mis 25
ans pour raconter son histoire et écrire
la vérité vous l'aviez vous pouviez pas
avant avant c'était n'y arriviez pas
non non non c'était pas penser à la fois
je n'avais pas la force vraiment oui
j'aurais dit et vos enfants ils sont
dans quel état d'esprit on pense quoi de
leur père ils savent quoi de leur père
ce oui comment comment vous le
laissions nerveuse
comment vous les avez accompagné
justement dans cette vérité dans cette
quête de la vérité
mais il faut l'appeler mais mon fils a
été la première personne qui à 22 ans a
eu la force de se me lever et de se
mettre face à la colombie pour demander
pardon au pays pour les péchés de son
père
ils voyagent dans le monde il faille
avec les jeunes leur montre que son père
n'est vraiment pas un modèle à suivre
cela fait trois ans au mexique
il a été nommé ambassadeur parlant mais
auprès de l'onu et il continue à y
travailler tous les jours merci dernière
question il ya une scène très forte où
vous êtes après la mort de pablo escobar
face aux représentants des cartels et
vous dise madame nous allons faire la
paix avec vous mais nous avons tué votre
fils est donc après c'est votre combat
pour qu'ils ne soient pas tués est ce
qu'aujourd'hui encore pour vous vos
enfants
parfois vous avez peur
non elle freine en compensation des
conversations très
[Musique]
très extrême
j'avais l'impression que je pouvais ne
pas sortir vivantes de série
je suis très croyant et je crois que
dieu m'a donné la foi cet amour pouvoir
au travers de ce genre de réunion
bcd des cyber à fait parce qu'il y avait
beaucoup de pablo escobar qu'étaient
réunis devant moi contre ma vie et
contre celle de manquer dont il ya eu
360 jours qui se sont écoulés et ils se
sont rendus compte de l'attitude mon
appartement et j'ai commencé à respecter
mon engagement joueurs paient en
propriété suivent qu'il n'avait demandé
puis à la fin ils sont écoutés monfils
avant qu on paie moi j'ai laissé ma vie
en échange
contre celle de monfils 6 sebastian s'il
n'était pas à la hauteur vraiment de
leur expérience d'achat de leurs tirs
grâce à dieu bien 27 ans se sont écoulés
et je n'ai pas eu alors été content
parce que sa vie est un exemple merci
maria isabel centre
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous